homeworld deserts of Kharak despite its
otherworldly setting creates believable
drama through stellar writing with a
mode of subtlety layered characters and
a pervasive all-consuming dread it
cinches the heart and holds you in
duress your ship is your mobile base of
operations in this fleet based strategy
game like others of its sort do gather
resources conduct research and build
units turrets and weapons of mass
destruction to field against your
opponents in battle karach chisels
Lizano down to its bare essentials and
iterates upon them with tenacious
precision making for a real-time
strategy masterpiece anyone familiar
with the strategy genre understands the
broad rock-paper-scissors planning that
forms its backbone there aren't any
massive research or Technology trees
here though unit and carrier upgrades
are still important but the focus of
minutes minute management falls onto
balancing unit types and their position
on the map the campaign while compelling
is only about ten hours long in the end
homeworld desert to karak is a fast
daunting experience that's tough to
shake making karate as intoxicating as
homeworld has ever been
you